the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so he graciously agreed to come today
and so everything is ready then and in
your cutoff is like 155 yeah
why is there
you know somebody changed the resolution
it seems but that's fine doesn't doesn't
bother us so I'm gonna tell you about
let's say one of the most ancient
optimization methods much simpler than
in fact the more advanced methods you
have already seen in class and
interestingly this more ancient method
remains the method for training
large-scale machine learning systems and
so there's a little bit of history
around that I'm not gonna go too much
into the history but the bottom line
which probably Gil has also mentioned to
you in class that at least for large
data science problems in the end stuff
reduces to solving an optimization
problem and in current times these
optimization problems are pretty large
so people actually started liking stuff
like gradient descent which was invented
by Cauchy back in the day and this is
how I'm writing the abstract problem and
what I wanna see is okay is it fitting
on the page this is my implementation in
MATLAB of gradient descent just to set
the stage that you know this stuff
really looks simple you've already seen
gradient descent and today essentially
in a nutshell what really changes in
this implementation of gradient descent
today is this part that's it
so you've seen gradient descent I'm only
going to change this one line and the
change of that one line surprisingly is
driving you know all the deep learning
toolboxes and all of large scale machine
learning etc this is an
oversimplification but morally that's it
so let's look at what's happening so I
will become very concrete pretty soon
but abstractly what I want you to look
at is the
kinds of optimization problems we are
solving in machine learning and I'll
give you very concrete examples of these
optimization problems so that you can
relate to them better but I'm just
writing this as the key topic that all
the optimization problems that I'm going
to talk about today they look like that
we're trying to find an x over a cost
function where the cost function can be
written as a sum in modern day machine
learning parlance these are also called
finite sum problems in case you run into
that term and this is called finite
because n is finite here in pure
optimization Theory parlance n can
actually go to infinity and then they
are called stochastic optimization
problems just for terminology if while
searching the internet you run into some
such terminology so you kind of know
what it means so here is our set up in
machine learning we have a bunch of
training data ok on this slide I am
calling x1 through xn these are the
training data the raw features later
actually I stopped writing X for them
and write them with the letter A but
hopefully that's okay so x1 through xn
these could be just raw images for
instance in imagenet or some other image
data set there could be text documents
they could be anything y1 through yn in
classical machine learning think of them
as plus minus 1 labels cat not cat or in
a regression setup as some real number
so that's a training data we have D
dimensional raw vectors and of those and
we have corresponding labels which can
be either plus minus 1 in a
classification setting or a real number
in a regression setting it's kind of
immaterial for my lecture right now so
that's the input and whenever anybody
says large-scale machine learning what
do we really mean
what we mean is that both N and D can be
large so what does that mean in words
there n is the number of training data
points so n could be these days what
million ten million hundred million
depends on how big computers and data
sets you got so n can be huge d the
dimensionality the vectors that we are
working with the raw vectors that can
also be pretty large think if X is an
image if it's a megapixel image wow
these like a million already if you are
somebody like kriti o or Facebook or
Google and you're serving web
advertisements D these are the features
could be like in 700 million even a
billion where they encode all sorts of
nasty stuff and information they collect
about you as users so so many nasty
things they can collect right so DNN are
huge and it's because both D and n are
huge we are interested in thinking of
optimization methods for large-scale
machine learning that can handle such
big dnl and this is driving a lot of
research also in theoretical computer
science including the search for sub
linear time algorithms in all sorts of
data structures in hashing tricks just
to deal with these two quantities so
here is an example super toy example and
I hope really you know by that I can
squeeze in a little bit of a proof later
on towards the end I'll take a vote here
in class to see if you are interested
let's look at the most classic question
least squares regression is a matrix of
observations or sorry measurements B are
the observations you're trying to solve
ax minus B whole square
of course a linear system of equations
the most classical problem in linear
algebra can also be written like that
let's say this can be expanded hopefully
you are comfortable with this norm right
so x2 square this is just defined as
that's the definition of that notation
but I'll just write it only once now I
hope you are fully familiar with that so
by expanding that I managed to write
least squares problem in terms of what I
call the finite sum right so it's just
going over all the rows in a their end
rows let's say so that's the least
squares classical least squares problem
it assumes this finite sum form that we
care about another random example
something called la so maybe you have if
anybody of you has played with machine
learning statistics toolkits you may
have seen something called la Sol la Sol
is essentially least squares but there's
another simple term at the end that
again looks like F of I support vector
machines once over horse of they're
still a workhorse horse of people who
work with small to medium sized data
deep learning stuff requires huge amount
of data if you have small to medium
amount of data logistic regression
support vector machines trees etc this
will be a first go to methods they still
very widely used these problems are
again written in terms of a loss over
training data so this again has this
awesome format which I'll just now
record here I may not even need to
repeat it sometimes I write it with a
normalization you may wonder at some
point why as that finite sum problem and
maybe the example that you want it to
see is something like that so deep
neural networks that are very popular
these days they are just yet another
example of this finite sum problem how
are they an example of that so you have
n training data points there's a neural
network loss like cross-entropy or what
have you squared loss cross into any
kind of loss why eyes are the labels cat
not cat or whatever or they may be her
multi class
and then you have a transfer function
called a deep neural network which takes
raw images as input and generates a
prediction whether this is a dog or not
that whole thing I'm just calling DN n
so it's a function of a eyes which are
the training data X are the weight
matrices of the neural network so I'm
just compressed the whole neural network
into this notation
once again it's nothing but an instance
of that finite sum so that F I in there
captures the entire neural network
architecture but mathematically it's
still just one particular instance of
this finite sum problem and in people
who do lot of statistics maximum
likelihood estimation this is log
likelihood over n observations we want
to maximize log likelihood once again
just a finite sum so pretty much most of
the problems that we are interested in
machine learning and statistics when I
write them write them down as an
optimization problem they look like this
finite sum problems and that's the
reason to develop specialized
optimization procedures to solve such
finite sum problems and that's where SGD
comes in ok so that's kind of just the
backdrop let's look at now how to go
about solving these problems
so hopefully this iteration is familiar
to you gradient descent right ok so just
for notation f of X refers to that
entire summation F sub I of X refers to
a single component ok so if you were to
try to solve that is to minimize this
cost function neural network SVM
what-have-you using gradient descent
that's what one iteration would look
like because it's a finite sum gradients
are linear operators
you know gradient of the sum is the sum
of the gradients so that's gradient
descent for you and now I'll just ask a
rhetoric question that if you put
yourself in the shoes of you know
algorithm designers some things that you
may want to think about what may you not
like about this iteration given that big
and Big D story that I told you so
anybody have any reservations or about
drawbacks of this iteration any comments
it's a pretty big sum especially
anything that is a big drawback and
there is that is the prime drawback for
large scale that n can be huge there can
be variety of other drawbacks some of
those you may have seen previously if
when people compare whether to do
gradient or to do Newton etc but for
purpose of today for finite sums the big
drawback is computing gradient at a
single point this is a subscript XK
missing there involves computing the
gradient of that entire sum that sum is
huge so getting a single gradient to do
a single step of gradient descent for a
large data set could take you hours or
days so that's a major drawback but then
okay if you identify that drawback
anybody have any ideas how to counter
that drawback at least say purely from
an engineering perspective I heard
something
using LexA and a batch of mash lights to
defend us and maybe somebody else has
essentially the same idea anybody wants
to suggest how to circumvent that big
end stuff in there anything suppose you
can implement in this what would you do
andum sample of the full n so these are
all excellent ideas and hence you folks
in the class have discovered the most
important method for optimizing machine
learning problems sitting here in a few
moments isn't that great so the part
that is missing is of course to make
sense of does this idea work why does it
work so this idea is really at the heart
of stochastic gradient descent so let's
see I maybe I can show you an example
actually that I I'll show you a
simulation I found on somebody's nice
web page about that so exactly your idea
just put in slight mathematical notation
that what if at each iteration we
randomly pick some integer I K out of
the n training data points and and we
instead just perform this update right
so you instead of using the full
gradient you just compute the gradient
of a single randomly chosen data point
so what have you done with that one
iteration is now n times faster if n
were a million or a billion wow that's
super fast but why should this work
right
I mean I could have done many other
things I could have constant I could
have not done any update and just output
the zero vector that would take even
lesser time that's also an idea means a
bad idea but it's an idea in the similar
league I could have done a variety of
other things why would you think that
just you know replacing that some with
just one random example may work let's
see a little bit more about that so of
course it's n times faster and the key
question for us here right now the
scientific question is does this make
sense it makes great engineering sense
does it make algorithmic or mathematical
sense so this idea of doing stuff in the
stochastic manner was actually
originally proposed by Robbins in Monro
somewhere I think around 1951 and that's
the most advanced method that we are
essentially using currently so I'll show
you that this idea makes sense but maybe
let's first just look at a comparison of
SGD with gradient descent in this
simulation so this is that MATLAB code
of gradient descent and this is just a
simulation of gradient descent as you
pick a different step size that gamma in
there you move towards the optimum if
the step size is small you make many
small steps progress and you reach there
that's for a well-conditioned problem in
an ill-conditioned problem it takes you
even larger in a neural network type
problem which is non convex you have to
typically work with smaller step sizes
and if you take bigger ones you can get
crazy oscillations but that's gradient
descent in comparison let's hope that
this loads correctly well there's even a
picture of Robbins who's a core
discoverer of the stochastic gradient
method there's a nice simulation that
instead of me
King that kind of deterministic descent
after all gradient descent is called
gradient descent at every step it
descends it decreases the cost function
stochastic gradient descent is actually
a misnomer at every step it doesn't do
any descent it does not decrease the
cost function so you can see at every
step those are the contours of the cost
function sometimes it goes up sometimes
it goes down it fluctuates around but it
kind of stochastically still seems to be
making progress towards the optimum and
stochastic gradient descent because it's
not using exact gradients just working
with these random examples it actually
is much more sensitive to step sizes and
you can see as I increase the step size
its behavior this is like actually full
simulation for a toy problem so
initially so what I want you to notice
is let me go through this you know a few
times keep looking at what patterns you
may notice in how that line is
fluctuating hopefully this is big enough
for everybody to see okay so this slider
that I'm shifting is just the step size
so let me just remind you in case you
forgot the iteration we are running XK
plus 1 is XK minus some it okay okay
it's called alpha there times some
randomly chosen data point you compute
its gradient this is SGD that's what we
are running and we threw away tons of
information we didn't use the full
gradient we just using this crude crude
gradient so this process is very
sensitive to the other parameter in the
system which is the step size much more
sensitive than gradient descent in fact
and you let's see as I vary the step
size see if you can notice some parents
on how it tries to go towards an optimum
is a zoomed in version also of this
later here and come to that shortly
again I'll repeat again and then I'll
ask you for your observations if you
notice some patterns I don't know if
they're necessarily apparent you know
that's the thing with patterns because I
know the answer so I see the pattern if
you don't know the answer you may or may
not see the pattern but I want to see if
you actually see the pattern as I move
change the step size so maybe that was
enough simulation anybody have any
comments on what kind of pattern you may
have observed any other comments there's
one more interesting thing happening
here which is a very very typical thing
for SGD in one of the reasons why people
love SGD let me do that once again
briefly okay this is tiny step size
almost zero close to zero is not exactly
zero so you see what happens for a very
tiny step size it doesn't look that
stochastic right but that's kind of
obvious from there if a Takei is very
tiny you'll hardly make any move so
things will look very stable and in fact
the speed at which stochastic gradient
converges that's why extremely sensitive
to how you pick the step size it's still
an open research problem to come up with
the best way to pick step sizes okay so
it's even though it's simple it doesn't
mean it's trivial and as I vary the step
size okay to make some progress and it
goes towards the solution are you know
beginning to say that it seems to be
making a more stable progress in the
beginning and when it comes close to the
solution it's fluctuating more and the
bigger the step size the amount of
fluctuation near the solution is Wilder
as he noticed back there but one
very interesting thing is more or less
constant there is more fluctuation also
on the outside but you see that the
initial part still seems to be making
pretty good progress and as you come
close to the solution it fluctuates more
and that is a very principally typical
behavior of stochastic gradient descent
that in the beginning it makes rapid
strides so you may see your training
loss decrease whoops super fast and then
kind of you know peter out and it's this
particular behavior which got people
super excited that hey in machine
learning we are working with all sorts
of big data I just want a quick and
dirty progress on my training training I
don't care about getting to the best
optimum because in machine learning you
don't just care about solving the
optimization problem you actually care
about finding solutions that work well
on unseen data so that means you don't
want to over fit and solve the
optimization problem supremely well so
it's great to make rapid initial
progress and if after that progress
Peters out it's okay
this intuitionistic statements that are
making in some nice cases like convex
optimization problems one can
mathematically fully quantify this one
can prove theorems to quantify its thing
that I said in terms of how close how
fast and so on we'll see a little bit of
that and this is what really happens to
SGD you know it makes great initial
progress and regardless of how you use
step sizes close to the optimum it can
either get stuck or enter some kind of
chaos dynamics or just behave like crazy
so that's typical of SGD and let's look
at no slight mathematical insight into
roughly why this behavior may happen
this is a trivial 1 dimensional
optimization problem but it conveys the
crux of why this behavior is displayed
by stochastic gradient methods that it
works really well in the beginning
then it can God knows what happens when
it comes close to the optimum anything
can happen so let's look at that okay so
let's look at a simple one dimensional
optimization problem I'll kind of draw
it out maybe on the other side so that
people on this side are not
disadvantaged so I'll just draw out a
least squares problem X is one
dimensional previously I had AI
transpose X now AI is also a scalar so
it's just 1d stuff everything is 1d so
this is our set up think of AI into X
minus bi these are quadratic functions
right so they look like this
corresponding to different eyes there's
like some different functions sitting
and so on so these are my n different
loss functions and I want to minimize
those we know we can actually explicitly
compute the solution of that problem
right you set so you set the derivative
of f of X to 0 so you set the gradient
of f of X to 0 hopefully that's easy for
you to do so if you do that
differentiation will get gradient of f
of X will be just given by well you can
do that in your head I'll just write it
out explicitly AI X minus bi times AI is
equal to 0 and you solve that for X you
get X star the optimum of this least
squares problem right so we actually
know how to solve it pretty easily it's
a really cool example actually I got
that from textbook by Professor Dimitri
butts acres now a very interesting thing
we are not going to use the full
gradient we are only you going to use
the gradients of individual components
right so what does the minimum of an
individual component look like well the
minimum of an individual component is
attained when we can set this thing to
zero and that thing becomes zero if you
just pick X equal to B I divided by AI
right so a single component we can be
minimized by that choice so you can do a
little bit of arithmetic mean geometric
mean type inequalities to draw this
picture
so overall I from 1 through n this is
the minimum value of this ratio AI bi bi
and let's say this is the max value of
AI bi bi and we know that closed-form
solution that is the true solution so
you can verify with some algebra that
that solution will lie in this interval
so let's so you you may want to this is
a tiny exercise for you hopefully some
of you love inequalities like me so this
is hopefully not such a bad exercise but
you can verify that within this range of
the individual mins and max is where the
combined solution lies so of course
intuitively you would have physics style
thinking you would have guessed that
right away so it means when you are
outside where the individual solutions
let's call this the far out zone and
also this side is the far out zone and
this region within which the true
minimum can lie you can say okay that's
the region of confusion why I'm calling
it the region of confusion because there
by minimizing an individual fi you're
not going to be able to tell what is the
combined X star that's all and a very
interesting thing happens now just to
gain some mathematical insight into that
simulation that I showed you that if you
have a scalar X that is outside this
region of confusion which states that if
you are far from the region within which
an optimum can lie so you're far away
you've just started out your progress
you made a random initialization most
likely a far away from where the
solution is so suppose that's where you
are what happens when you're in that far
out region so if you're in that far out
region
you use a stochastic gradient of some
eyuth component so the full gradient
will look like that a stochastic
gradient looks like this one component
and when you are far out outside that
min and Max regime then you can check by
just by just looking at it that a
stochastic gradient in the far away
regime has exactly the same sign as the
full gradient
what does gradient descent do it says
well walk in the direction of the
negative gradient and if far away from
the optimum outside the region of
confusion your stochastic gradient has
the same sign as the true gradient may
be in more linear algebra terms it makes
you know it makes an acute angle with
your gradient that means if even though
a stochastic gradient is not exactly the
full gradient it has some component in
the direction of the true gradient this
is 1d here it is exactly the same sign
in multiple dimensions this is the idea
that it will have some component in the
direction of the true gradient when
you're far away which means if you then
use that direction to make an update in
that style you will end up making solid
progress and the beauty is in the time
it would have taken you to do one single
iteration of batch gradient descent far
away you can do million stochastic steps
and each step will make some progress
and that's why you we see this dramatic
initial again this is in the 1d case
this is explicit mathematically in the
high D case this is more intuitive ok
without further assumptions about angles
etc one can't make such a broad claim
but intuitively this is what's happening
on why you see this awesome initial
speed
and once you inside the region of
confusion then this behavior breaks down
some stochastic gradient we have the
same sign as the full gradient some may
not and that's why you can get at crazy
fluctuations so this simple 1d example
kind of exactly shows you what we saw in
that picture and people really loved
this initial progress because often we
also do early stopping you know train
for some time and then you say ok I'm
done so importantly if you are purely an
optimization person not thinking so much
in terms of machine learning when please
keep in mind that stochastic gradient
descent or stochastic gradient method is
not such a great optimization method
because once in the region of confusion
it can just fluctuate all over forever
and in machine learning you say oh the
region of confusion that's fine it'll
make my method robust gonna make my
neural network training more robust will
generalize better etcetera etcetera we
like that so it depends on which frame
of mind you are in ok so that's that's
the awesome thing about the stochastic
gradient method so I'll give you now the
key mathematical ideas behind the
success of SGD this was like little
illustration very abstractly this is an
idea that records throughout machine
learning and throughout theoretical
computer science and statistics any time
you're faced with the need to compute an
expensive quantity resort to
randomization to speed up the
computation SGD is one example the true
gradient was expensive to compute so we
create a randomized estimate of the true
gradient and the randomized estimate is
much faster to compute and
mathematically what will start happening
is
depending on how good your randomized
estimate is your method may or may not
converge to the right answer so you of
course one has to be careful about what
particular randomized estimate one makes
so but really abstractly even if I
hadn't shown you the main idea this idea
you can apply in many other settings if
you have a difficult quantity come up
with a randomized estimate and save on
computation this is a very important
theme throughout machine learning and
data science okay and this is the key
property so stochastic gradient descent
it uses stochastic gradients stochastic
is here just used very loosely you know
it just means there's some randomization
that's all it means
and the property the key property that
we have is in expectation the
expectation is over
whatever randomness you used so if you
picked you know some random training
data point out of the million then it is
the expectation is over the probability
distribution over what kind of
randomness you used if you like picked
uniformly at random from a million
points then this expectation is over
that uniform probability but the key
property for SGD or at least the version
of SGD i am talking about is that in
expectation over that randomness the
thing that you are pretending to use
instead of the true gradient in
expectation actually it is the true
gradient so in statistics language this
is called the stochastic gradient that
we use is an unbiased estimate of the
true gradient and this is a very
important property in the mathematical
analysis of stochastic gradient descent
that it is an unbiased estimate and
intuitively speaking anytime you did any
proof in class or in the book or lecture
notes wherever where you were using true
gradients more or less you can do those
same proofs more
less not always using stochastic
gradients by replace by encapsulating
everything within expectations over the
randomness I'll show you an example of
what I mean by that I'm just trying to
simplify that for you and in particular
the unbiasness is great so it means I
can kind of plug in these stochastic
gradients in place of the true gradient
and I'm still doing something meaningful
so this is answering that earlier
question you know why this random stuff
why it should we think it may work but
there's another very important aspect to
it why it works beyond this unbiasness
that the amount of noise or like the
amount of amount of stochasticity is
controlled so just because it is an
unbiased estimate doesn't mean that it's
going to work that well why because it
could still fluctuate hugely right
essentially plus infinity here minus
infinity here you take an average you
get zero so that is essentially unbiased
but the fluctuation is gigantic
so whenever talking about estimates
what's the other key quantity we need to
care about beyond expectation
in clearance and really the key thing
that governs the speed at which
stochastic gradient descent does the job
that we want it to do is how much
variance do the stochastic gradient have
just this simple statistical point in
fact is at the heart of a sequence of
research progress in the past five years
in the field of stochastic gradient
where people have worked really hard to
come up with newer and newer fancier and
fancier versions of stochastic gradient
which have the unbiasness property but
have smaller and smaller variants and
the smaller the variance you have the
better your stochastic gradient is as a
replacement of the true gradient and of
course the better is the replacement of
the true gradient then you truly get
that you know n time speed-up okay so
the speed of convergence depends on how
noisy the stochastic gradients are it
seems like I'm going too slow I won't be
able to do a proof i if it sucks but
I'll but let's let me actually tell you
then about rather than the the proof
I think I'll share the proof with Gil
because the proof that I want to want
you to actually show you talk gives a
proof of stochastic gradient is
well-behaved on both convex and non
convex problems and the proof I wanted
to show was for the non convex case
because it applies to neural networks so
you may be curious about that proof and
remarkably that proof is much simpler
than the case of convex problems so let
me just mention some very important
points about stochastic gradient so even
though this method has been around since
1951 every deep learning toolkit has it
and we are studying it in class there
are still gaps between what we can say
theoretically and what happens in
practice and I'll show you those gaps
already and encourage you to think about
those if you wish
so let's look back at our problem and
tell you about two variants so here are
the two variants I'm going to ask if any
of you is familiar with this variant
in some way or the other so let's I just
call it feasible here there are no
constraints so I start with any random
vector of your choice in deep network
training you have to work harder and
then this is the iteration you run right
option one and option two so option one
says that was the idea we had in class
randomly pick some training data point
use it stochastic gradient well what do
we mean by randomly pick the moment you
use the word random you have to define
what's the randomness so one randomness
is uniform probability of our n training
data points that is one randomness the
other version is you pick a training
data point without replacement so I so
with replacement means you know just
uniformly at random each time you draw a
number from one through n use that
stochastic gradient move on which means
the same point can easily be picked
twice also and without replacement means
if you've picked a point number three
you're not going to pick it again until
you've gone through the entire training
data set those are two types of
randomness which version would you use
there is no right or wrong answer to
this I'm just taking a poll what would
you use think that you're writing a
program for this and maybe think really
pragmatically practically so that's
enough of an hint which version would
you use I'm just curious who would use
one please raise hands who and the the
exclusion the compliment they reform I
don't know maybe some people are
undecided who would use two very few
people okay how many of you use neural
network training tool kits like
tensorflow pi torch whatnot which
version are they using
actually every person in the real world
is using version 2 are you really gonna
randomly go through your RAAM each time
to pick random points they'll kill your
GPU performance like anything what
people do is take a data set use a pre
shuffle operation and then just Boop
stream through the data what the
streaming through the data mean without
replacement so all the toolkits actually
are using the without replacement
version even though intuitively the rent
just uniform random feels much nicer and
that feeling is not ill-founded because
that's the only version we know how to
analyze mathematically so even for this
method everybody studies it their
million papers on it the version that is
used in practice is not the version we
know how to analyze it's a major open
problem in the field of stochastic
gradient to actually analyze the version
that we use in practice it's kind of
embarrassing but it's without
replacement means non iid probability
theory and non iid probability theory is
not so easy
that's the answer okay so the other
version is this mini batch idea which
you mentioned really early on is that
rather than pick one random point I'll
pick a mini batch so I had a million
points each time instead of picking one
maybe I'll pick 10 or 100 or thousand or
what have you
so this averages things averaging things
reduces the variance so this is actually
a good thing because the more quantities
you averaged the less noise you have
that's kind of what happens in
probability right so we pick a mini
batch and the stochastic estimate now is
this you know not just a single gradient
but averaged over a mini batch so mini
batch of size one is the pure vanilla
SGD mini batch of size n is nothing
other than pure gradient descent
something in between is what people
actually use
and again the theoretical analysis only
exists if the mini-batch is picked with
replacement not without replacement so
one of the reasons actually a very
important thing in theory you don't gain
too much in terms of computational gains
on convergence speed by using mini
matches but mini batches are really
crucial especially in you know deep
learning GPU style training because they
allow you to do things in parallel each
thread or each core or sub core or small
chip or what-have-you depending on your
hardware can be working with one
stochastic gradient so mini batch is the
larger the mini batch the more things
you can do in parallel so mini batches
are greatly exploited by people to give
you a cheap version of parallelism and
where does the parallelism happen you
can think that each core computes a
stochastic gradient so the hard part is
not adding these things up and making
the update to X the hard part is
computing a stochastic gradient so if
you can compute 10,000 of those in
parallel because you have 10,000 cores
great for you and that's the reason
people love using mini batches but a
nice side remark here this is also this
brings us close to the research edge of
things again that well you'd love to use
very large mini batches so that you can
fully max out on the parallelism
available to you right maybe you have a
multi GPU system if you're friends with
NVDA or Google I only have like two GPUs
but it depends on how many GPUs you have
you'd like to really max out on
parallelism so that you can really
crunch through big datasets as fast as
possible but you know what happens with
very large mini batches so if you have
very large mini batches stochastic
gradient starts looking more like full
gradient descent which is also called
batch gradient descent that's not a bad
thing that's awesome for optimization
but it is a weird conundrum that happens
in training deep neural networks this
type of problem we wouldn't have for
convex optimization but in deep neural
networks this is really disturbing thing
happens that if you use this very large
mini-batches your method starts
resembling gradient descent that means
it decreases noise so much so that this
region of confusion shrinks so much
which all sounds good but it ends up
being really bad for machine learning
that's what I said that in machine
learning you want some region of
uncertainty and what it means actually
is a lot of people are have been working
on this including at big companies that
if you reduce that region of uncertainty
too much you end up overfitting your
neural network and then it starts
sucking in its test data unseen data
performance so even though for
parallelism programming optimization
Theory big mini-batch is awesome
unfortunately there's price to be paid
it hurts your test error performance and
there all sorts of methods people are
trying to cook up including shrinking
data accordingly or changing neural
network architecture and all sorts of
ideas you can cook up your ideas for
your favorite architecture how to make a
large mini batch without hurting the
final performance but it's still
somewhat of an open question on how to
optimally select which many larger
mini-batch so should be so even though
these ideas are simple you see that
every simple idea leads to an entire sub
area of SGD so here are practical
challenges people have various
heuristics for solving these challenges
you can cook up your own but it's not
that one idea always works so if you
look at SGD what are the moving parts
the moving parts in SGD the gradients
stochastic gradients the step size the
mini batch so
how should I pick step sizes very
non-trivial problem different deep
learning toolkits may have different
ways of automating that tuning but it's
one of the painful things which
mini-batch to use with replacement
without replacement I already showed you
but which mini-batch should I use how
large that should be again not an easy
question to answer how to compute
stochastic gradients does anybody know
how stochastic gradients are computed
for deep Network training anybody know
there is a very famous algorithm called
back propagation that back propagation
algorithm is used to compute a single
stochastic gradient some people use the
word back prop to mean SGD but what back
prop really means is some some kind of
algorithm which computes for you a
single stochastic gradient and hence you
know this tensorflow etc these toolkits
they come up with all sorts of ways to
automate the computation of a gradient
because really that's the main thing and
then other ideas like gradient clipping
and momentum etc there's a bunch of
other ideas and the theoretical
challenges I mentioned to you already
proving that it works that it actually
solves what it set out to do
unfortunately I was too slow I couldn't
show you the awesome five line proof
that I have that SGD works for neural
networks and theoretical analysis as I
said it's really lagging my proof also
uses the with replacement and the
without replacement version which is the
one that is actually implemented there's
very little progress on that there is
some progress there's a bunch of papers
including from our colleagues at MIT but
it's quite unsolved and the biggest
question which most of the people in
machine learning are currently excited
about these days is stuff like why does
SGD work so well for neural networks we
use this crappy optimization method it
very rapidly does some fitting data is
large neural network is large
and then this neural network ends up
having great classification performance
why is that happening
it's called trying to explain build a
theory of generalization why does this
an SGD train neural network work better
than neural networks train with more
fancy optimization methods it's a
mystery and most of the people who take
interest in theoretical machine learning
and statistics that is one of the
mysteries they are trying to understand
so I think that's my story of SGD and
this is the part we skip but it's ok the
the intuition behind SGD is much more
important than this so I think exactly
yeah I think so that they'll be great